we are celebrating the summer issue of
Drew magazine all show long and now here
to talk about her must-haves for the
beach is someone we must have it is the
queen of tick tock and Sirius XM radio
it's your big sister tinks everybody
[Applause]
um okay in this issue you give some
must-haves yes what are tinks must-haves
just things that you absolutely need for
the summer my favorite season that is
coming up well you are literally
following the beach
exactly the ocean and I think you know
it is a summer issue so let's have some
fun in the sun take it away tinks so
here are my summer must-haves I am
obsessed with these Freedom Moses
sandals because feel how lightweight
they are they're so light and I love
them for the beach because they don't
get hot and they're so lightweight they
can fall in the pool they're waterproof
I know I'm kind of inching towards
middle age because everything I say is
like about practicality I'm like you
could throw in the pool they don't get
hot I love that yeah if you have me with
middle age I love it
what's next I Love Too Faced I love this
blush I'm so lucky to work with them
truly it's an incredible blush I like so
much blush that I like borderline clown
me too but but that just makes me feel
alive and it makes me look alive too so
I'm a big blush girl and this is my pick
for summer all right well you can get it
with Too Faced number three
okay I am such a granola girl I love
working with Sakara they are amazing
this granola is so fab I eat it year
round but in the summer with a little
cold almond milk it's everything it's so
crunchy it's so delicious put it on
yogurt it's just chef's kiss I have to
say no hyperbole this is the best it's
like granola I've ever had no way good
and they're it's like you know female
founded
amazing brand it just makes you feel
good inside the coconut it's just
delicious so like I don't know if these
are like outside
oh my God I love to take it away from me
I could stop eating literally that is
Yoga Sakura used to make
[Applause]
all right and most importantly last you
have a book coming out
my birthday
my book is all about shifting your
perspective when it comes to dating
because I spent so much time in my 20s
asking oh does he like me does he like
me does he like me never once stopping
to ask myself wait do I even like him
and so this book is all about these
little perspective shifts that you can
make to your mindset so that you can
date from a place of abundance and joy
and it's not as stressful as it is right
now can I ask any other tips like
because you're so right we don't ask if
we actually like them it is so much do
they like us people are literally
nodding I am completely at fault of that
and that's probably my more
any other advice things I'm single and
we all have been I mean I really when I
was looking back at my 20s I mean and
there's a lot of mishaps and missteps
that I made in my 20s that I put in the
book because I'm all about learning from
others mistakes and I want people to
learn from my mistakes but I really just
think that so many young people try to
change themselves to get into a
relationship and that's not the way to
go you want to love yourself first as
you are and fill up your own cup and
date from that place and I promise that
a better partner will drop in if you if
you date that way see this is why okay
I love you thank you
sister and we need you I love you I love
you so much you guys guess what also we
have an audience giveaway everyone in
the audience is going home with the
sandals the blushing highlighter and the
Granola that I just discovered is the
best
and most importantly everybody go out
and grab jinx's book this shift is
available now because I got to tell you
every time I listen to you I feel better
and I do better thank you thank you
thank you all right
three tips for your best summer growth
and I'll try to finish this we'll be
right back
[Music]
my happy place is being at home with a
cup of coffee and doing some arts and
crafts I find doing coloring very
therapeutic and calm
[Music]